hello this is Matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to cover what is a
docker container why you would want to
consider using it in your DevOps
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have with in a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the benzene level so we're able to
get rid of the guest OS and we're able
to eliminate the hypervisor environment
and this is really important as we
actually start working and creating
environments that are consistent because
we want to be able to make it so it's
really easy and stable for the
environment that you have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look at a container as an example
so here we actually have a couple of
examples on the right hand side we have
different containers we have one
containers running Apache Tomcat and
with Java and second containers running
sequel server and microsoft.net
environment third container is running
Python with my sequel these are all
running just fine
within the docker engine and sitting on
top of a host OS which could be Linux it
really could be any host OS
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to have a solution that can
be shared easily amongst your teams so
let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional Java application so you have
your developers working in jboss on his
system and he's coding away and he has
to get that code over to a test and now
what will happen is that tester will
then typically in your traditional
environment
then have to install JBoss on their
machine and get everything running and
cook and hopefully set up identically to
the developer chances are they won't
have it exactly the same but the try get
as close as possible and then at some
point you want to be able to test this
within your production environment so
you send over to a system administrator
who would then also have to install
j-bars
on their environment as well yeah this
just seems to be a whole lot of
duplication so why go through the
problem of installing JBoss three times
and this is where things get really
interesting because the challenge you
have today is that it's very difficult
to almost impossible to have identical
environment if you're just installing
software locally on devices the
developers probably got a whole bunch of
development software that could be
conflicting with the JBoss environment
the tester has similar testing software
but probably doesn't have all the
development software and certainly the
system administrator won't have all the
tools that the developer and tester have
their own tools and so what you want to
be able to do is kind of get away from
the challenge you have of having to do
local installations on three different
computers and in addition what you see
is that this uses up a lot of effort
because when you're having to install
software over and over again you just
keep repeating doing really basic
foundational challenges so this is where
docker comes in and docker is a tool
that allows you to be able to share
environments from one group to another
group without having to install software
locally on a vise you install all the
code into your docker container and
simply share the container so in this
presentation we're gonna go through a
few things we're gonna cover what docker
actually is and then we're gonna dig
into the actual architecture of docker
and kind of go through what docker
container is and how to create a docker
container and then we'll go out through
the benefits of using docker containers
and then the commands and finalize
everything out with a brief demo so what
is darker so docker is as you'd expect
because all the software that we cover
in this series is an open source
solution and it is a container solution
that allows you to be able to
containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution that you're building
so you could share it from different
people in your team whether it's a
developer a tester or system
administrator and this allows you to
have a consistent environment from one
group to the next so let's kind of dig
into the architecture so you understand
why docker ones effectively so the
docket architecture itself is built up
of two key elements there is the docker
client and then there is a REST API
connection to a docker daemon which
ecchi hosts the entire environment
within the docker host and the doctor
Daymond you have your different
containers and each one has a link to a
docker registry the docker client itself
is a rest service so as you'd expect a
REST API and that sense command line to
the docker daemon through a terminal
window or command line interface window
and we'll go through some of these demos
later on so you can actually see how you
can actually interact with docker the
dock atom then checks the request
against and the docket components and
then performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create container
and again this is consistent with all
the DevOps
tools that we have the DevOps tools that
we're looking to use throughout this
series of videos are all environments
that can be scripted and this is really
important because it allows you to be
able to duplicate and scale the
environments that you want to be able to
build very quickly and effectively the
outer container itself has all of the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one package thing
to think of it as a really effective and
efficient zip file it's a little bit
more than that but it's one file that
actually has everything you need to be
able to run all of your solutions the
actual dr. registry itself is an
environment for being able to host and
distribute different doggett images
among your team so say for instance you
had a team of developers that were
working on multiple different solutions
so say you have a team of developers and
you have 50 developers and they're
working on five different applications
you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in the container so the
important part of a ducking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and learn exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
the actual folder itself is much smaller
it's very secure highly portable and the
boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you would
actually create a docker container so
the docker container itself is actually
built through command line and it's
built of a file and docker image so the
actual docker file is a text file that
contains all the instructions that you
would need to be able to create that
docker image and then will actually then
create all of the project code with
inside of that image then the image
becomes the item that you would share
through the document you would then use
the command line and we'll do this later
on so that docker 1 and then the name of
the image to be able to easily and
effectively run that image locally again
once you've created the dog image you
can store that in the docker registry
making it available to anybody within
your network so something to bear in
mind is that dr. itself has its own
registry called docker hub when that is
a public restroom so you can actually go
out and see other dock images have been
created and access those images as your
own company you may want to have your
own private and repository so you want
to be able to go ahead
and either do that locally through your
own repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of docker hub working
at you then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a docker
image using some of our basic docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command and another
one is to actually put it into your
registry which is a push command so if
you want to get a image form a docker
registry then you want to use the pull
command and a pull command simply pulls
the image from the registry and in this
example using ng INEX
as our registry and we can actually then
pull the image down to our test
environment on our local machine so
we're actually running the container
within docker application on a local
machine we're able to then have the
image run exactly as it would in
production and then you can actually use
the run command to actually use the
docket image on your local machine so
just a you know a few interesting
tidbits about the docker container once
the container is created a new layer is
formed on top of the document layers
called The Container layer each
container has a separate read/write
container layer and any changes made in
that docking container is then reflected
upon that particular container layer and
if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also gets
deleted as well so you know why with
using docker and containers be of
benefit to you well you know some of the
things that are useful is that
containers have no external dependencies
for the applications they run once you
actually have the container running
locally it has everything it needs to be
able to run the application so there's
no having to install additional pieces
of software such as the example we gave
with jade glass at the beginning of the
presentation now the containers are
really lightweight so it makes it very
easy
to share the containers amongst your
teams whether it's a developer or
there's a tester whether it's somebody
on your operations environment it's
really easy to share those containers
amongst your entire team different data
volumes can be easily reused and shared
among multiple containers and again this
is another big benefit and this is a
reflection of the lightweight nature of
your containers the container itself
also runs in isolation which means that
it is not impacted by any dependencies
you may have on your own local
environment so it's a completely
sandboxed environment so some of the
questions you might ask us you know can
you run multiple containers together
without the need to start each one
individually and you know what yes you
can with docker compose Dokken compose
allows you to run multiple containers in
a single service and again this is a
reflection on the lightweight nature of
containers within the darker environment
so we end our presentation by looking at
some of the basic commands that you'd
have within docker so we have here on
the left hand side we have docker
container then the command for each item
we're actually going to go ahead and use
some of these commands and the demo that
we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have our committing the
docket image into the container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stopped
working then we start those containers
but suddenly you can look at all the
image all of the commands here and try
them out for yourself so we're going to
go ahead and start a demo of how to use
the basic commands to run docker so to
do this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line to bring whether
you're on a Linux PC or Mac and we're
gonna go ahead and the first thing you
want to do is see what our doggett image
lists are so we can go sudo docker
images and this will give us well first
we'll enter in our password so let's go
enter that in and this one that give us
a list of docker
and here are the dark energies I have
already been created in the system and
we can actually go ahead and actually
see the processes that are actually
running so I'm gonna go ahead and open
up this window a little bit more but
this will show you the actual processes
and the containers that we actually have
and so on the far left hand side you see
under names we have learned simply learn
beyond school cool these are all just
different ones that we've been working
on so let's go ahead and create a docker
image so we do sudo dock
run
- D - P 0.0.0.0 go on 80 : 80
Ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run Anna Bunty
in egde and this around the latest image
and what we have here is a hash number
and this hash number is a unique name
that defines the container that we've
just created and we can go ahead and we
can check to make sure that that
container actually is present so we're
gonna do sudo docket RPS and this
actually shows some there so it's not in
a running state right now but that
doesn't mean that we don't have it so
let's list out all the containers that
are both running and in the exit so it's
do sucker PS dash a and this lists all
the containers that I have running on my
machine and this shows all ones that
have been in the running state and in
the exit state and here we see one that
we just created about a minute ago and
it's called learn and these are all
running ubuntu and this is the one that
we had created just a few seconds ago
let's open it up and there we go so
let's change that to that new duck
container to a running state so scroll
down and we're gonna type sudo
duck
[Music]
run - IT - - name my and so this is
gonna be the new container name it's
gonna be my docker
so this is how we named our environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
Ubuntu and - Ben - bash and it's now in
our root and we'll exit out of that so
now we're gonna go ahead and start the
new my docker container so sudo docker
start my and we'll give the container
image which will be my docker my docker
return and that started that docker
image and let's go ahead and check
against the other running docket images
to make sure it's running correctly so
sudo docker PS and there we are
underneath name on the right hand side
you had to see my daugher along with the
other docker images that we created as
been running for 13 seconds quite fast
so we want to rename the container
that's used the command sudo docker
rename we can take another target image
this scrap this one and we'll put it in
rename and we'll rename opening the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
proof zooming called image is now called
purple so do pseudo docker PS
to list all of our docker images
and if we screw up and they're there we
go purple how easy is that to rename an
image and we can go ahead and use this
command if we want to stop container so
we're going to write sudo docker
stop and then we have to put it in the
container name and we'll put in my
darker at the container that we
originally created and that image has
now stopped and let's go ahead and prove
that we're going to list out all the
docket images and what you see is that
it's not listed in the active images
it's not on the list on the far right
hand side but if we go ahead and we can
list out all of the docket images so you
actually see it's still there as an
image is just not in an active status
what's known as in an exit state so here
we go
and there's my dacha it's in an exit
state so that happened
27 seconds ago
so if we want to do remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker are our am will remove my
dacha and that will remove it from the
exit state
and we're going
go ahead and we gonna double-check that
and yeah
yep it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore it's gone
there we go they work that's where it
used to be all right
let's go back
so if we want to exert a container in
the running state so we do pseudo kale
and then the name of the container I
think one of them is called yellow let's
just check and see if that's going to
kill it
oops no I guess we don't have one called
'yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have so sudo
daca kill we're gonna list out all the
ones that running oh okay there we go
now yellow isn't in that list so let's
take I know this takes simply learn and
so we can actually go ahead and let's
write sudo daca kill simply learn and
that will actually kill an active docker
container boom there we go
and we list out all the acts of
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active anymore and these are all the
basic commands for dr. container so
hopefully you learned a little bit about
dr. containers here we're really
interested if you have any additional
questions on how dr. containers work and
how you would use them within your own
environment
have any questions certainly feel free
to add your questions below in the
comments and then if you liked our video
hit subscribe and hit the bell button so
you're always notified about future
videos that we are doing we do several
new videos every single week and we're
really doing a lot of stuff on dev ops
at the moment so this is Matthew from
simply learn checking out hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simply learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here